We made it.
I'm Fujita, I work for Mr. En.
Nice to meet you.
Huh? Uh, yeah.
Her boob is sticking out. Is that right?
I'm Fujita, nice to meet you.
Is that in right now?
Thank you for waiting.
Please come this way.
I will take your masks and coats.
I didn't need to fix it, then.
Sorry, senpai.
See, I told you I dressed nicely.
She's a girl?
You're late.
Ah, cut the crap.
Here is your aperitif.
It's been a while, Noi. How have you been?
What's this?
It's a Kir Martini.
Don't ignore your cousin.
You're cousins?
Is Noi being helpful, Shin?
I am, aren't I?
Braised? What does that mean?
So, about your new assignment.
En, I don't want to deal with any more
assignments with multiple targets.
It's messy and I'm fed up
with having to kill lots of weak guys.
Don't worry.
Your next target is just a team of two.
I hear they're pretty tough, too.
Right, Fujita?
Huh? You mean these two
are going to kill that lizard guy?
Is he strong?
Magic doesn't work on him,
so you must kill him with your bare hands.
With my bare hands...
Senpai!
I'm in.
Hey, put that back, Ebisu! Stop!
Noi, I want you to fix Ebisu.
I'm interested in who cast the spell
on the lizard guy.
Ebisu uses lizard Magic,
so she might know something.
Senpai, let's have a kilo of steak!
It's En's restaurant anyways.
Let me tell you about the lizard guy
and his female friend.
Welcome.
Sit back, relax,
and enjoy our transformation show.
-Aitake.
-And Maitake.
Nice to meet you.
Shape-shifting Sorcerers, huh?
Must be hard work, too.
Wow, they can turn into celebrities
and stuff, right?
Transforming!
Looks weak.
Do I look like him?
Hey, can we have a drink too?
Were you the one
that picked up my call today?
Yes. Did you like your calf's liver?
I only eat mushrooms, you fakes.
It's too late now!
You doofus, getting tricked like that!
Why did you use a fork?
Use a knife, for Christ's sake.
Don't get me wrong, Noi.
I was just having a little fun.
-Damn it.
-Run!
Fools.
Find the real Aitake and Maitake.
They should be somewhere.
If they're dead,
use their bodies to grow mushrooms.
Cook these as usual.
What?
You mean the mushrooms we just ate...
I hate wasting good mushrooms.